ATTORNEY WHOSE WIFE AND SON WERE
MURDERED THREE MONTHS EARLIER.
>>> "OUTFRONT" TONIGHT,
PRESIDENT BIDEN FACING
REPUBLICAN OUTRAGE OVER HIS
COVID-19 VACCINE POLICIES THAT
WILL IMPACT UP TO 100 MILLION
AMERICANS.
>> WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE CALLING YOUR
VACCINE REQUIREMENTS AN OVER
REACH WHO ARE THREATENING TO
CHALLENGE IT IN COURT?
>> HAVE AT IT.
LOOK, I AM SO DISAPPOINTED THAT
PARTICULARLY SOME OF THE
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS HAVE BEEN
SO CAVALIER WITH THE HEALTH OF
THESE KIDS, SO CAVALIER WITH THE
HEALTH OF THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS -- THIS IS -- WE'RE
PLAYING FOR REAL HERE.
THIS ISN'T A GAME.
>> HE'S REFERRING TO REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS BECAUSE SOME OF THEM
ARE PILING ON THE OUTRAGE.
THE GOVERNOR OF SOUTH CAROLINA
HENRY McMASTER TWEETING REST
ASSURED WE'LL FIGHT THEM TO THE
GATES OF HELL TO PROTECT THE
LIBERTY AND LIVELIHOOD OF EVERY
SOUTH CAROLINAEN AND THEN THERE
IS THIS.
>> WHAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS DOING IS GOVERNMENT OVER
REACH, PURE AND SIMPLE.
>> MY LEGAL TEAM IS ALREADY
WORKING, AND WE WILL DEFEND AND
PROTECT OUR PEOPLE FROM THIS
UNLAWFUL MANDATE.
>> WHEN WE SEE ELECTED OFFICIALS
VIOLATE THE CONSTITUTION, WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO FIGHT
BACK, AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING.
>> YOU SHOULD NOT LOSE YOUR JOB
JUST BECAUSE JOE BIDEN IS HAVING
THIS HISSY FIT.
>> IN THE HALLS OF CONGRESS, THE
RESPONSE FROM ELECTED OFFICIALS
TED CRUZ CALLING IT UTTERLY
LAWLESS AND MARSHALL BLACKBURN
IS SAYING BIDEN IS SOUNDING LIKE
A DICTATOR EVERY DAY AND STEVE
SCALISE ACCUSING BIDEN OF BEING
A DESPERATE POLITICIAN ABUSING
POWER AND NOT TO BE OUT DONE.
RIGHT WING MEDIA CUT TO THE
CHASE.
>> WE HAD TO ELECT THIS ROTTING
BAG OF OATMEAL TO GET A REAL
TYRANT.
JOE BIDEN.
>> JOE BIDEN COULDN'T GET HIS
ACT IN ORDER SO HE DECIDED TO
ISSUE A TYRANT AND AUTHORITARIAN
ORDER HERE.
>> TIME FOR FACTS AND NOT FAKE
CALLS OF TYRANNY.
FACTS YOU THINK THE GOP WOULD
EMBRACE BECAUSE CAN YOU BELIEVE
THIS ACTUALLY GOES BACK TO
GEORGE WASHINGTON?
YES.
VACCINE MANDATES HAVE BEEN PART
OF THE UNITED STATES SINCE 1777.
1777.
WHEN GEORGE WASHINGTON REQUIRED
HIS TROOPS THE IMMUNIZED FOR
SMALLPOX.
LAST I CHECKED, PRETTY MUCH
ANYTHING GEORGE WASHINGTON DID
IS SACRED TO THE REPUBLICANS
SLAMMING BIDEN FOR FOLLOWING
GEORGE WASHINGTON'S PRECEDENT.
I TOOK YOU BACK TO 1777 BUT
ACTUALLY DON'T NEED TO DO THAT.
I CAN SHOW YOU WHAT THE VERY
SAME REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS CALLED
TYRANNY AGAINST BIDEN ARE DOING
THEMSELVES IN THEIR STATES.
YES, EVERY SINGLE STATE IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA HAS A
FORM OF A MANDATE FOR CERTAIN
VACCINES FOR STUDENTS.
LET ME JUST GIVE YOU SOUTH
DAKOTA WHERE GOVERNOR CHRISTIE
GNOME AS YOU HEARD CALLED
BIDEN'S PLAN AN UNLAWFUL
MANDATE.
PERHAPS SHE SHOULD LOOK IN THE
MIRROR BECAUSE SHE HAS A VACCINE
IN HER STATE FOR SCHOOL
CHILDREN.
I'LL READ IT TO YOU.
HER POLICY, HER STATE.
ANY CHILD ENTERING SCHOOL OR
EARLY CHILDHOOD SHALL REQUIRED
TO ADMISSION BE REQUIRED TO
PRESENT CERTIFICATION FROM A
LICENSED PHYSICIAN THAT THE
CHILD HAS RECEIVED ADEQUATE
IMMUNIZATION AND GOES ON TO LIST
THE ILLNESSES.
RUBELLA, CHICKEN BOX, MUMPS,
IT'S OKAY FOR HER BUT NOT FOR
BIDEN?
I'M NOT SURE WHAT EXCUSE SHE'D
MAKE FOR THE GEORGE WASHINGTON
PRECEDENT.
VACCINES WORK THANKS IS WHY
SOUTH DAKOTA AND EVERY OTHER
STATE IN THE COUNTRY REQUIRES
THEM, HAS MANDATES FOR THEM LIKE
THE COVID VACCINES WORK NOW.
JUST TO REMIND EVERYBODY WHAT
THOSE REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS KNOW
FULL WELL UNVACCINATED AMERICANS
ARE TEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE
HOSPITALIZED WITH COVID AND 11
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO DIE THAN
VACCINATED INDIVIDUALS.
KAITLAN COLLINS IS "OUTFRONT" AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
KAITLAN, SOUNDS LIKE THE
PRESIDENT IS RELISHING THIS
FIGHT WITH THE GOP.
>> Reporter: ERIN, HE WAS
CERTAINLY EXPECTING IT WHEN HE
UNVEILED THE MEASURES YESTERDAY.
IT DIDN'T TAKE LONG TO SEE THE
GOVERNORS PUSHING BACK AND THEY
KNEW IT WAS COMING.
YOU'RE SEEING THE PRESIDENT CALL
OUT REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS AS YOU
SAID.
HE MAY NOT ALWAYS SAY THEIR NAME
EXPLICITLY AND THAT'S PART OF
THE BROADER SHIFT AS HE'S
GROWING INCREASINGLY MORE
FRUSTRATED WITH THESE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS STANDING IN THE WAY OF
VACCINATING MORE AMERICANS OR
ENCOURAGING MORE AMERICANS TO
GET VACCINATED BUT WITH THE
PEOPLE YET TO GET VACCINATED.
YET DESCRIBING IT AS AFAILURE
ASKING 80 MILLION AMERICANS TO
DO SO.
IT IS REMAINING TO BE SEEN HOW
THIS WILL PLAY OUT FOR PRIVATE
COMPANIES BECAUSE IT'S STILL
BEING DRAFTED BY THE LABOR
DEPARTMENT AND NOT OFFICIALLY
UNVEILED YET.
A LOT OF DETAILS ARE IN FLUX HOW
THE ENFORCEMENT IS GOING TO
WORK, WHO IS GOING TO PAY FOR
THE TEST IFS YOU'RE A WORKER AT
A COMPANY AND CHOOSE NOT TO GET
VACCINATED, IS IT YOU PAYING FOR
IT OR THE BUSINESS?
THESE ARE DETAILS WE'RE LEARNING
TO FIND OUT WHEN THEY UNVEIL
THIS IN THE COMING WEEKS.
WE SHOULD NOTE THE FIGHTS ARE
FAR FROM OVER.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS NOT TAKING
OTHER MEASURES OFF THE TABLE.
WHEN ASKED WHETHER THEY WOULD
CONSIDER A VACCINE TO GET ON A
FLIGHT DOMESTICALLY HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES, SOMETHING
RECENTLY IS NOT REQUIRED, THEY
SAID THEY ARE NOT TAKING IT OFF
THE TABLE AND WOULD DO ANYTHING
IN THE END THAT WOULD HELP SAVE
LIVES.
>> THANK YOU.
LET ME GO TO DR. MARTY, AND
DAVID FROM SENIOR EDITOR OF THE
"ATLANTIC."
DR. MARTY, YOU LIVE WHERE THE
GOVERNOR THERE CALLED THE STANCE
OF VACCINES A HISSY FIT FIGHTING
BACK ON PRESIDENT BIDEN'S ORDER.
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU ABOUT THIS
PUSH BACK FROM DeSANTIS?
>> I THINK THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE
PLAYING POLITICS WITH SOMETHING
AS SERIOUS AS THIS DISEASE.
THE VACCINE IS INCREDIBLY SAFE.
IN FACT, YOU COMMENTED ABOUT THE
VERILATION, WHICH IS RECOMMENDED
BY GEORGE WASHINGTON BACK IN THE
17 00s AND I SHOULD ADD THAT HE
HAD MARTHA WASHINGTON IN FRONT
OF EVERYONE TAKE THE VERILATION
TO SHOW HIS TROOPS THAT IT WAS
SAFE, AND ACTUALLY, THAT WAS
INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS COMPARED TO
THE VACCINES WE HAVE NOW, WHICH
ARE INCREDIBLY SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE, AND THE COMBINATION
OF USING THE VACCINES AND THE
NON-PHARMACEUTICAL INTERVENTIONS
ARE OUR BEST WAY OUT OF THIS.
ANYONE WHO ISN'T ON BOARD WITH
THAT IS NOT PARTICIPATING IN THE
BEST CITIZEN SHIP THAT SHOULD
EXIST IN THIS COUNTRY AND THAT
IS GOING FOR EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE INCLUDING THE GOVERNORS.
>> SO DAVID, ALL OVER AND I KNOW
SOME STATES IT IS DIFFERENT,
BUT, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE, AMERICANS
SUPPORT PEOPLE AND VACCINE
MANDATES AND BUSINESSES REALLY
WANT IT, RIGHT, BECAUSE IT'S
PROCAPITALISTS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT OTHER
PROTECTIONS AND OF COURSE, THE
GOVERNORS THEMSELVES FIGHTING IT
HAVE MANDATES THEMSELVES SO IT'S
HYPOCRITICAL HOWEVER, THEY
DECIDED COMING OUT AND SAYING
THIS AND FIGHTING BIDEN IS THE
RIGHT POLITICAL MOVE AND WILL
HELP THEM.
WILL THEY END UP BEING RIGHT?
>> THEY ARE GOING TO END UP
BEING SO WRONG.
I WILL HEAR THE CAUTION AGAINST
PLAYING POLITICS AND I WILL
DRIVE RIGHT PAST IT.
I WOULD LIKE PEOPLE TO CONSIDER
IF WE WEREN'T TALKING ABOUT THIS
VACCINE ISSUE TODAY, 70% OF THE
COUNTRY IS ON THE PRESIDENT
'S SIDE AND 30% IS OTHER.
YOU MIGHT TALK ABOUT THE RISING
PRICE OF BEEF, CHICKEN AND PORK
BUT VERY LITTLE A PRESIDENT CAN
DO BUT WILL BE BLAMED AND CRIME
NUMBERS THAT ARE EVALUATED FROM
FOUR, FIVE YEARS AGO.
NOT A LOT THE PRESIDENT CAN DO
BUT THE PRESIDENT WOULD BE
BLAMED.
WE WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THE
SITUATION ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, THIS HUGE IMMIGRATION
ISSUE AND THE TERRIBLE IMAGES
FROM AFGHANISTAN.
ALMOST EVERYTHING ELSE WE MIGHT
BE TALKING ABOUT IS A 70/30
ISSUE IN THE REPUBLICANS' FAVOR
BUT BIDEN HAS TRACKED THEM INTO
TALKING ABOUT AN ISSUE WHERE
THEIR BASE IS FORCING REPUBLICAN
OFFICE HOLDERS INCLUDING PEOPLE
WHO ARE PRETTY -- I MEAN, GREG
ABBOTT IS SOMETHING OF A TRUE
BELIEVER BUT CHRISTIE GNOME AND
DeSANTIS ARE NOT TRUE BELIEVERS.
THIS IS A GOOD THING TO RAISE
MONEY ON.
IT EXCITES THE REPUBLICAN $20
GIVER BUT DOESN'T EXCITE PEOPLE
IN THE SUBURBS AND ESPECIALLY
WOMEN OF THE SUBURBS WHO ARE
PEOPLE THE REPUBLICANS NEED TO
WIN BACK.
BIDEN IS NOT THINKING ABOUT THE
POLITICS BUT THE MANEUVER HE'S
EXECUTED IS POLITICALLY
POWERFUL.
>> KEEP IN MIND, DeSANTIS IS
FIGHTING TO HIS COURT AFTER
COURT AGAINST BUSINESSES IN HIS
OWN STATES WHO ARE SAYING WE
WANT VACCINE MANDATES, THE
CRUISE SHIPS.
THEY WANT IT FOR THEIR BUSINESS
AND HE'S FIGHTING AGAINST
BUSINESS.
IT'S THE MOST COUNTER GOP THING
I'VE HEARD IN QUITE SOMETIME.
BUT DR. MARTY, IF GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS OR GOVERNOR GNOME,
GOVERNOR DUCY SUCCEEDS IN
STOPPING BIDEN'S RULES, WHAT
WILL IT MEAN?
WILL THE IMPACT BE IN THE
CONTEXT WHERE PEOPLE UNDER 12
CAN'T GET VACCINATED AND YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO REQUIRE THE 85
MILLION AMERICANS WHO COULD TO
GET IT?
>> HE'S NOT GOING TO SUCCEED.
OSHA HAS THE AUTHORITY, WHICH IS
WHERE THIS HAS BEEN PLACED BY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO
ASSURE SAFETY IN WORKPLACES, AND
ALREADY, THERE ARE MANY OSHA
MANDATES THAT EMPLOYERS HAVE TO
MEET TO BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL REGULATIONS, AND ALREADY
OSHA ALREADY SINCE JANUARY HAS
HAD THINGS ON THE BOOKS, SOME OF
WHICH ARE MANDATORY, SOME OF
WHICH ARE RECOMMENDATIONS
RECORDING COVID-19.
MORE OVER, OSHA HAS RULES ON THE
HEPATITIS B VACCINE BUT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT ONLY AFFECTS ONE
PERSON THAT MIGHT GET HEPATITIS
WHEREAS BEING VACCINATED NOT